okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about handling of
historical entities in our language and
some of our merry band are having
technical difficulties so will be with
us soon but we're gonna start on a piece
of this agenda that we can handle now
okay so this is functions for date
interval arithmetic yeah and I just sent
you a supplemental notebook with sort of
the current state of date interval but
so this particular example I don't think
is super interesting in the agenda
because it doesn't actually give us a
meaningful interval there's not an
intersection between those two points
but if you have a prototype build these
evaluations will run okay we can look at
the existing now let's look at the
examples but I'll also talk to prototype
build yeah and so sort of the the two
pending questions that we have with the
design of date interval is whether it
will need to automatically include a
granularity specification by the way
that's a that's encouraging the some
uncaught to throw and the long I think
it's uh open ma'am I don't work here
okay fine so let's take a look date
interval of today mm-hmm that test way
to specify that if I might say so yeah
we were looking at doing some
intelligent detection to say oh this is
a this is obviously a day or a week or a
month I think what we should say is um
first of all we might be able to do
something with that little funny thing
which I'm not the wildest on that I
can't in fact but I mean I think that
icon could get a little softer it's a
little hard harsh invisible but but then
we could imagine something where there's
a little bar and here that indicates
that's an interval and then we could say
18th April 29 paren whole day or
something to indicate that it's the data
interval representing the whole day
him yeah I think they could make sense I
know we could say you know a whole week
whole but we don't need to say whole
week we'd say whole month April 20 April
2019 paren whole month and then mm-hmm
what we'd start with is and then and
then this icon would change slightly
I make so we'd have the icon vary
depending on the those are interval or
not whether it's an interval whether
it's an air ball now okay I I would say
we just do something that indicates you
know interval mess and that icon okay so
as a general design question there's I'm
I still don't have a solid opinion on
whether we want to say there's a
granularity associated with the interval
such that if I have all of this year but
the thing I'm interested in is sampling
basically every day whether that is part
of the interval specification or that's
part of the function that operates on it
I understand the issue the underlying
thing is that in that object we have
included both the instant object and the
object so but under granularity you say
so in other words you're saying it is
anchored to this instant the day around
this instant is that correct well it's
not so much that as the representation
so who could have created a separate
object for the continuous point-wise
object and the granular discrete object
but do we have the same so now that we
have intervals of of point-wise objects
the question is whether we want also the
interval of discrete objects okay so
the difference between day and whole day
so the granular day is the discrete
single object that identifies a day is
like a different type while an interval
that extends for a day is the collection
of all instance of that day this is a
different thing right okay so one thing
is the granular object the other is the
union of all instance within that object
exactly so the representation of this as
a day tenth of all we will be literally
calling this day tenth of all but would
it have the same innards or would it
have a instant to instant set of innards
the current notion is to go from instant
to instant we have the there's the
general question of the representation
of instance in handling open and closed
points yeah it the general current idea
is that you have first included instant
and either first excluded instant or
last included instant you know the
current notion right now basically is
inclusive so that's why we get machine
reals on the second point when we look
at some of the other outputs okay and so
then the question sort of is is there a
meaningful difference between an
interval that is this entire year from
the first instant of it until the last
and one that's that same period of time
but we essentially say the granularities
in days so it's every day between there
but it's not necessarily at least
semantically the same as every instant
within that time period I understand so
the default date interval would be every
instant just as the default date object
is an instant correct but then the idea
would be that there is a granular date
object that means the
bag of granular things so in other words
one could take given any date object
that has granularity one could in
principle resolve that date object into
the collection of granular objects that
it contains yes yeah like the difference
between interval from 1 to 3 and span 1
2 3
so span is just the integers well the
interval is all the reals so here we see
maybe we should call it date span yeah
we were kind of thinking about that and
then do we just have the default date
span be instant to instant or is there a
meaningful reason to have both the date
interval and date span and I think
probably not yeah well I mean so the
default would be to take for granted or
ities of the two endpoints right if
those granularities agree then you have
it made
I claim and then you default to that now
what if the guy out is don't agree so
generally our precedent has been for
things like date range where you can
give a start date and end date is we
implicitly assume that the granularity
is the granularity of the starting date
and we go out through the end of the
granularity of the end date okay okay so
that's not stupid I think that's a quite
sensible way to do it I mean I think
it's very weird if the if the end date
okay but so in date span for example
it's gonna be hard to understand so date
range if I say date range of today comma
today what do I say today plus five days
for example
okay magnificent so those are the that
is so in other words what we could
imagine is date range of a date span
yeah so so for comparison if you do date
range of today comma next date month the
second one is a month granular object
and the two ways we can interpret that
are either why didn't that autocomplete
we have an open ticket on that or
looking at with Tom so in this case you
get all of the dates in June as well
because you specified a month granular
object so we're not stopping at the
beginning of June we're going through
the end of June and I think Oh a month I
see next date will now give me June in
that case mm-hmm okay okay
okay so date and to validate span I'm a
little concerned about date span I think
date interval may be clearer than date
span yeah I guess the the other concern
is when we call it date interval then we
need to follow the precedent of interval
fairly closely I would think and we I
don't know that there's a strong case
for multi intervals of dates at the
moment and the way that interval handles
the rounding out of the endpoints to
handle machine epsilon is also a little
different than what we necessarily want
for dates why well just in terms of the
the notion of how we want to handle open
versus closed in dates I know we're
gonna have the same issue of is this
before that and so on the same issue is
on the number line mm-hmm yeah I don't
see why we're gonna why it should be any
different from that now the question is
whether it needs the extra level of list
bracket because interval how does
interval work and to all has some yeah
it has a list of mins and maxes that's
kind of stupid well 1990
six not probably the best decision
ideally with dates we would have
something that is closed on their left
and open on the right so that we can
partition exactly the time axis without
overlapping I see well okay so the multi
interval concept I mean I can see that
being useful for dates you know every
how every Tuesday becomes a data
interval of a bunch of Tuesdays right I
mean it's a multi interval how else are
we going to represent that I mean we
could imagine having those min Max's
could be potentially single date objects
with granularity hmm right as a
convenience right now date interval if
you give it a so it follows the current
syntax of interval where it's expecting
a start date and an end date but if you
just give it a granular date it will
automatically round it out to its
endpoints okay fine well then I think
it's perfectly reasonable to say date
interval and have that be something that
can be in every Tuesday type thing well
I think interval is going to be like the
non expanded representation of things if
we want to expand like two very many
days then we will have the concept of
date array which is the efficient way of
packing tons of the dates oh yeah but
listen one of the other things we need
is every Tuesday from now until the end
of the year how do we represent that let
me make another comment actually that
one of the things that drives me
absolutely bonkers with the calendar
system with our calendar system is a
recurring meeting is forever like really
really forever like I've had recurring
meetings that have been going for like
several years and then we change it and
the thing just is extending out you know
into the next century and that's really
annoying and
I think that they just don't have a good
representation for you know repeating
things that don't repeat forever I'm
making a sense so what is what is our
idea for how to do that having some sort
of general language for date selections
and having a date select that you accept
various ways of specifying periodicities
etc but then at the end once we expand
it we resolve it into something large
potentially very many dates our idea is
to have a data ring similar to quantity
array exit why do we need that I mean
unless we're talking all the way back to
the you know the dinosaur day is anybody
not know yeah we the calendar is hard to
extend back to them given that there's
no evidence that one knows the precise
day you know the asteroid arrived type
thing but unless we're going all the way
back to that when are we ever gonna have
enough dates that anybody's gonna care
well we may need it for I'm serious
thing we'll have thousands of points and
we want to manipulate all the points or
the dates fast I see I see I see so that
that's when you have a lot of date
instance rather than eight dates so it's
more like time I mean are we imagining
that there's a time interval as well as
that as a date interval are you sure it
will be easy to construct based on the
other one but I don't think we have ever
talked about not really I mean time
object is kind of it's kind of a subset
of the notion we've had of either
headless dates or recurring dates where
you know we're chopping off sort of the
higher order elements of a calendar I
type we're gonna need some kind of
notion of time at all
I claim that's gonna be useful yeah I
guess the the other question about
calling a date interval is that there I
mean I guess it isn't really spans sort
of has a notion where we could put
granularity in the elements and interval
doesn't really especially for gonna
allow multi intervals there's not
necessarily enough so your proposal is
that the multi thing is handled in some
different way so right I think we should
have some idea of of how we're going to
do this multi thing before we lock in on
this design um but I think that okay so
the question is if it was date span um
doesn't I mean date span yeah it
suggests granular stuff to me well so
then what you imagine for date span is
is the same thing as span where you're
doing the initial the final step right
right so this would have a beginning
ending so effectively the same arguments
of date object but the first one is up
there beginning
well is it a pair with the list or is it
begin end grand granularity I think it
has to be like that date span begin and
granularity yeah they'd be consistent
with spans notation which means argument
searcher okay but then what would happen
okay okay so if you give date span a
single date object then what that would
mean is the whole of it so to speak
see another question is so if you re
granular eyes so if I say date object of
now comma minutes okay so that's now
been granular
that's now that that is a specific
minute
yes but so now what I want to do is I
want to regrain your eyes a day into a
date span which is the sequence of its
minutes you see what I'm saying yeah
also spine has this element of the stick
or increment I don't know how well I
mean we're imagining using that as
granularity but I'm afraid I think it's
a little different right because you
first me not there yeah I mean I'm
beginning to think this is not going to
work here
Mack or hover it said on our livestream
it's pointing out that I caused a good
recurrence grammar well it sure doesn't
get used in in the Zimbra implementation
um I think we've looked at that in the
past but we should look at that again
I mean we've also got a representation
of this in um
scheduled tasks right yeah scheduled tes
has it it also has a reference to cron
notations since that's used pretty often
in scheduling
right yeah we have without general
street versions of those of hourly daily
etc sure but but the the cron version
okay okay so this is this is another
analogy here um but let's come back to
I'm beginning to cool on the date span
idea because I think that's you know
again well we've got
the notion of date range which will
actually enumerate for you the dates
right correct
I mean I'm really beginning to think
date interval is what it's about because
it's a date interval but but I don't
know how we deal with granularity then
well I guess the that would be the
alternate approach would be that the
granularity is something that is
relevant to whatever function is
operating on it
I don't like only reason we're doing
that is because we interval I would say
again date object it's just that the
first arguments up there say that again
sorry we mutate date object but the
first argument is a pair beginning and
yeah I understand but the problem of
that is that then we don't have the
ferals behavior of interval what about
the possibility of having date object
take a list as its first argument it
already takes date lists so we wouldn't
be able to specify dates in other
formats other than the object itself and
I will interpret that as an interval but
maybe as a list of dates that would be
an extension I'm not thrilled about the
idea of having an interval with a
different with a mean so so the argument
would be do an interval with begin end
and a granularity argument there if we
want to have a numeric can begin and end
then we could have calendar semantics
sitter okay but but okay so
we're doing that we're blowing away the
multi interval version which might be
okay because we might have another way
of doing the the union of date intervals
perhaps here we add a new list so it
could be single pair or at least afters
that's grotesquely incompatible with
interval yes but in date interval we
need additional arguments no I
understand all right well so that but at
least we could start off with this
concept now let's take a look at what
you're talking about here um so a date
interval that defines the granularity of
objects inside the interval right the
granularity of where the so for example
that could be the first day of the month
the last of the month and that's minutes
that right
yeah that would represent every minute
in that interval okay without having to
list them right right and then and so
then among other things date range of
add a tenth of all should resolve it it
could I mean right now range of interval
doesn't expand the interval because the
interval there doesn't doesn't have
granularity yeah I think if if we do
sort of have this notation break with
traditional intervals and we have a
stronger case for being able to use as a
start and so I could that could be made
to work that might be an interesting
thing to make work I mean I've never
really needed it but it might be an
interesting thing to make work well it
can be applied yeah I could be applied
okay but but
this alright so what's the other case
here let's just look at this so one of
the questions is about instantiation of
the intervals so our central dogma with
granular dates is that if you have a
function that needs a specific instant
and it's operating on a data object with
a granularity larger than an instant it
takes the first applicable moment so if
I have this year and I feed it into you
know air temperature data and it says I
need a specific instance it will get the
first moment of this year but it doesn't
necessarily give up time to I guess yeah
air temperature date is a bad example
here all right okay so air temperature
data of today for example I'm predicting
should give a time series well what is
it that's not right why does it give a
time series I think Jason was looking at
okay so if I say of you know last month
is that gonna give a date object
correctly yeah okay that's not imply the
way what that did it wasn't very
beautiful and should probably be fixed
what the heck oh right right so this is
the notion that it's it's giving an
interval because you entered in a single
date and so we wanted to give back out a
single value corresponding to the
granularity okay but so what how would I
get the time series for today I know
that if I do a time series if I do
something like yesterday comma today
then I'll get the time series but now
which day what time series does that go
up to that goes up to the what the heck
that's going up to the beginning of
today which is arguably not what it
should be doing mmm yeah I think Jose
you might remember I remember we had a
conversation with Jason about this and I
believe our notion was that if to give
something like the time series back we
we're expecting to have an input like a
date interval and we don't have that at
the moment but the idea would be if you
you know if I put in a single date
object then I should get a single value
back but if I put a date interval in
then I would automatically get the time
series value back because I have a start
date and an end date and potentially a
sampling so unreasonable so in other
words would be a temperature data of
date interval of today hmm could
potentially give a sampling of hours for
instance and then that could return
intervals for each hour or it could
return you know actual values right yes
so that's the idea that a date object
it's always a discrete single object an
intersection of them it's so what what
time does that say it's for I mean when
is that for I don't know how its
computed but it's either an average or I
don't know there's resolution with which
we get 15 minutes 15 minutes so it's
perhaps knowledge hmm okay but so air
temperature data may have a um an
aggregator for that right okay so let's
just summarize where we're at here we've
got date range would resolve things date
interval has a begin end on a
granularity the granularity represents
so what it represents is the range of
things from beginning to end with that
internal granularity right okay yep and
then I think the formatting should be um
I would recommend something like the
following so just like it would say well
if the granularity is the same as so it
would say something like hold a colon
bla bla bla bla so I'm saying to
represent the interval that represents
the interval from beginning to end but
that's with
um well let's say I mean the other thing
we might do is each minute in or every
minute in what do you think I mean that
that's to represent what it means if I
have this entire year and the
granularity is a minute well for example
in another case it would be every every
day in well it might even say in year
1960 but it could just say go ahead what
are you gonna say the case is a case
having different beginning and end so I
think what they should do is is to have
like the most common cases like from 5th
to 6th of May or from May 5th to June
6th of this year
right so okay so then then you're saying
you factor out the year here in January
right so and I don't even understand how
that negative interval works there but
let's say 27 to 28 through 28 January
2019 for example and maybe the through
yeah like you do that with lighter color
yeah
and then our worst case scenario is
basically two instance that don't have
you know it's from 37 seconds past the
hour of this until blah and then we may
have the full typeset form look like it
currently does an X okay so if the
granularity disagrees with the implied
granularity of these things here right
mm-hmm
then we would say something like every
minute in 27 through 28 January 2019
that makes sense yeah I think that
should be pretty easy to detect okay all
right by the way where am i saving this
stuff anybody know I have a its
historical the rest oh you know it's
okay let's now I think we have everybody
else here so let's some let's go ahead
and start talking about the other stuff
if we're done with the data interval
discussion yeah I think there should be
enough for me to get started okay great
okay times polygons and date intervals
in time series okay
well as we previously spoke on the
meetings before I was recalled parklets
we checked we had currently we return a
list of dates and polygons and what was
suggested to use this as to work this is
a time series which we have already been
working on and made a time series to
work for that okay well hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on okay so this is
polygon time series and so what you're
saying is if I were to enter to simplify
this a bit if I were to enter so that's
the entity and if I were to enter this
to be clear that I should be able to say
here dated of polygon comma all correct
okay dad should return a list right now
okay but that's incompatible with other
uses of that and my advice say for
instance is taking it a while but and
and also we have to do better caching
for this right
okay well that's magnificent
okay so first of all so there are many
bugs here I mean these should be data
objects granular data objects of some
kind right or actually in the case of
historical countries they should
presumably be data intervals am i right
we're still uh well we have our pull
request on the review in order to treat
this as a time series so we are doing
these with an interpolation order with a
sampling method of interpolation with a
hold from left so we just have the
endpoint there are the start point and
then we go until the next step of these
time series okay so you'll get a time
series and then that's fine um but in
general the time series should have data
objects rather than these raw that I
mean it doesn't really matter it can it
can deal with date lists but but um so
what it's implicitly doing then
okay well I think that's the look it's
the right thing to make this a time
series right correct
okay so then but by the way we choose
this format initially because that was
compatible with the daily list as the
blood functions and that means blood
functions what function rate so the
blood functions are really work with
pairs of late least less value so what
happens if I say to this date let's plot
it's gonna be garbage right now because
because the value is a polygon that if
you have the area for example it works
oh so let's so let's imagine what I do
here is I say if I take a you know hash
wonka maggio area of hash - and I do
that on this right
is that gonna work cool a Soros at sea
okay now the only issue with that is
that it does the incorrect holding right
in other words it's a plating between
it's like poor whoever it was you know
Caesar when he conquered Gaul or
something you know it'll show this will
be very you know this will interpolate
Caesars you know trip across goal which
is undoubtedly not correct whereas what
we have is discrete points where we know
you know that things happened and we
don't we don't we make the approximation
that things only happen when we knew
they happened am I making sense right
the way we shall be with this template
instead of regular this plot which is
simply interpolation so what are you
saying is that like this okay but that
will happen automatically if this thing
is constructed into a time series
correct because the time series will
have the whole from left attribute set
right right okay
now another question I have we have geo
list plot do we need any kind of geo
dateless plot
wouldn't that be a good thing to have I
mean couldn't we what would it do
I mean you could imagine something which
has some kind of contours or something
okay is there anything meaningful for it
to do
if you were animating there's something
to do but otherwise is there something
meaningful part to do yes I think that
was movie what we will do it with a time
series as input for plots functions for
G opal but generally you're saying we
have to figure that out or you have an
idea no no my only idea would be to
actually get the values and plot them
all together we would need some kind of
shape wait yeah well so I mean I think
the obvious thing to do would be to
stack them on top of each other and to
have essentially an opacity and the more
the more the thing has been there the
darker it gets
I don't know if anybody can think of a
better idea
I think I agree with that perhaps with
some too deep or something like that for
there yes yeah that's possible I mean in
other words so like a contour plot gives
the levels this is effectively giving I
mean what this is is a density plot it's
a little bit of a weird thing I mean if
we do this for Gio we probably should be
able to do this for just a collection of
you know polygons in a time series I
mean it seems more useful for the Geo
case but you get what I'm saying there's
nothing that makes this special with
respect to geo versus anything else you
could you could do by stacking polygons
you could have polygons and a time
series as well now presumably we should
make things like geo area operating on
the time series just work operate your
own time series of polygons do the right
thing all right so what is there to
figure out here so this is so the only
issue there is to specify the ending
point because we have this until some
year it's really not specify in this
list so is the last polygons but it and
in some date and that will be specified
in the time series object yeah but right
now there is no way to decide that the
time series has some way to specify what
I mean I mean do we have that in the
data in the underlying data I mean yes
we know and you which data the country
existed that's for ten ad or something
for the Roman Empire or maybe yeah I see
but but now okay so that's there like
the domain of the of the time series so
an extra I thought the time series had
that
or is it the case that time series just
looked for the last point
well I mean you know what we would have
to do in the current design of time
series is replicate the last point right
well we were thinking about adding a
missing as last point after that we will
get missing
I see missing country doesn't exist
right right but but I will prefer to
have some kind of way to spin slightly
domain are they thank serious little
well okay but that's the time series
questions anybody from the time series
team here yes okay can you comment on
that
that go sure I couldn't because you
provide the time timestamps and so this
is this is a collection of you know of
pairs time body pairs so we don't we
don't specify the domain because you
don't have you know the domain is
specified by the first time and last the
last time yeah I know I understand yeah
it's on life right there in the hold
from left story where is hold from left
its home from left part of the
resampling method yes right but so the
issue these guys have is they're doing
hold from left and then they need an end
point if you're doing interpolation you
don't need an end point because you know
there's no place to go other than an
anchor point that's there out at the end
right but there's the suggestion and
they made it they note and you know the
end of the end point after which there
is nothing and they can put the missing
so but whose okay but Francisco is
asking for an actual domain okay what
what happens if you say duration of the
time I mean in the case where there's a
thing with a missing at the end the
duration of the time series would give
the correct value would it not no it's
gonna give you the the span over the
time stamps I understand that but so
what what it's over there in the way
it's independent of the older values
because it's giving you things that I
know so is the right thing so I mean let
me let me edit my Roman Empire I'm gonna
take only the late Roman Empire here
okay and then I'm gonna do this and then
what we're saying is it says next when
did when the robe for was at 410 AD I
remember that correctly
then it would look like that
is that correct okay so now my question
to you Gosha is if I ask for duration of
this time so let's say I make this into
a time series okay let's actually do it
okay and now I say duration of that time
series oh for God's sake that is a
stupid unit you know we should be doing
a better job of what why on earth does
it do that
it should be giving years here
well that that's a separate issue that
it should be inheriting the granularity
of the data objects you get what I'm
saying well that's on to duties because
right now it's not okay I'm fine
it should be okay but in any case this
so that is for 10 minus 272 times 365
yes is that right is that what it
computed here Oh 400 thing no it's got
leap years and everything in there right
yes yes so it's right so it did compute
the right thing okay so so let's be
clear this will give the right answer if
we go to the last point here and we say
after that point it's missing then so
far as we know that will compute all the
right things correct I think that values
of that time series you're going to get
the missiles flock if you do values of
the time series you're gonna get garbage
because you're going to see you know
you're going to see an independent of
dates and then who knows what you get I
mean in other words the the issue here I
mean it's a closed versus open interval
issue
right what if you want to compute things
you should be able to use delete missing
and then compute but it also gives you
the idea where the things and so if you
ask for the you know for the time series
at the date 500 it's gonna give you
missing because it's gonna interpolate
from the last you know holes from the
left so if you do if you if you ask for
a time series but I mean the value for a
hundred eighty here it's not gonna do
something stupid is it where it gives
that value because it needs to really
have a missing a pre missing as well
it's gonna extrapolate well it can't do
that sorry it can't do that so that's
why these guys are asking for a domain
for the time series because it
absolutely cannot do that and by the way
are there any cases and I can imagine
for some historical things that the
thing is happily humming along and then
there is a missing period in the middle
and then it goes back and hums along
again yes yes okay so how do we
represent that because this isn't gonna
cut it to have yeah so what do you want
to do for that well if you know which
dated stopped existing you can also put
your notes I understand that let's
assume that this is the start date okay
let's take a look I don't really know
what I don't know my Roman you know I
don't know who that does that
Augustus or something I don't know what
that was anybody know Roman history well
enough to know um anyway let's imagine
you know there was some start date like
700 BC or something for the Romulus and
Remus or whatever it was then that's
probably a suppose II start date but
there is a definite start date and it
better not be the case that if I ask for
the Roman Empire before 27 BC that I get
you know it should just say missing
right
all right yeah so how are we going to do
that go show what do we put into the
time series to get that to work well you
need in that case that would be the
missing again it's no no no no no look
look we're agreeing that we could do a
hold from left idea where we put a
missing at the end to represent when the
thing goes out of existence but well
okay so you could argue that the
convention is bad here this is a mess
look the point is that we've got one
piece of information that's missing from
this this picture here which is what the
end date was we've got the start date
but we don't have the end date right
which is unfortunate in asymmetric so
the truth is the way this should be
represented is and in this is wrong and
that's why we're getting into trouble
the correct way to do this is to have a
time series of intervals right of date
intervals because if we said date
interval from 27 to blah blah blah you
get this from 389 to 410 you get this
then we be in good shape and then we
just have some sort of strict endpoint
rule that says if you ask outside either
the endpoints it's considered an invalid
query that's right and by the way
standard on live stream is talking about
why don't we have an interpolation
extrapolation separately but I don't
think that's right because the country
could have had you know there could be
time series where it's missing in the
middle so I think what we have to have
is something where there are a series of
intervals and the way those intervals
are set up they knit together so that
they form a continuum when combined but
if you land in your probe somewhere
other than on an interval it says
missing because that's the nature of our
data the data says from minus 27 BC to
minus 19 BC the area of the Roman Empire
was blah and then and then on from there
this is the right way to do it so that
would be a really de Vence serious when
we would
allow the time stamps that you have this
this spread in time because the event
series by default does not interpolate
in between your time stamp but maybe
that's right then maybe that's that's
the way because the time series you know
by default is to interpolate that's
that's their purpose in life and this
one about this is the really Dave and
serious you want the missing when the
things are not okay so let's take a look
at something else so some boy this is
really a moment of I mean you know we
really have to understand what we you
know a notion of history here because if
I do the following if I say something
like um New York City and then I say
dated population comma all I am going to
get a time series right and if I say
date let's plot it is going to look at
that it's gonna join the points alright
so if I say dateless plot percent 22
mesh arrow all okay it joined the points
now for population we think that's
reasonable boy that is really wild
because for area which we probably do do
you think we have the area of New York
City historical time series okay but
let's imagine that we did then it's
almost certainly wrong to do this this
joining up business that is quite subtle
so for what characteristics you know
it's it's kind of like boy how would we
distinguish properties that are
plausibly joined up from properties that
are not plausibly joined up I mean
things that are determined by regulation
or by conquest are probably not joined
up but for example in early times in
history before there were clear borders
it could be that the area
changes continuously you know some
random nomadic tribe is wandering out
into the steppe somewhere but in case
the state did not exist so we didn't
make sense to talk about true I you know
back in early anybody know a really
early I'm really early well let's try or
is or a a considered an early
civilizations okay so let's do yes well
I know that but I'm just wondering
whether Oh made it on its own as a
city-state okay whoever made it as a
city-state so let's just do a journalist
plot of law that is really wild Wow what
do you think those puppies are what well
yes obviously okay well I wonder what
okay so first question is what year did
it pick for this I think it picks the
maximum extent doesn't it right now the
good news is we have a polygon with
holes here which is very high-tech but
okay but so clearly okay this is a bad
example but I could imagine an example I
don't know maybe there's something and I
don't know where Africa maybe I don't
know one of the early things there um
where you really just have something
which is expanding into a vacuum right
so that it so it would make sense to
have continuous expansion let's some how
do we get the earliest date here
okay so if I say geo list plot oops
Julis plot dated or oh my gosh why is
this beeping crazy okay
2700 BC alpha goodness sake what did it
do that why does why does it not have a
series for did you understand what I'm
asking
it's come on
okay so we have polygons from the 2047
BC okay well why did this not work okay
well whatever the start date is we
better have some polygons bone back to
the start date um okay so let's go back
so what are you saying so if I say 1900
BC for example am I finally what the
heck come on what's going on here
there's something famous right with that
when was the well the Rhind papyrus was
a different civilization but that was
what what is going on here
help where did it go
that did it or disappear by that time
okay somebody is suggesting on the on
the livestream this the growth of the US
that is a good idea so if I say USA and
now I say like 1820 luiso because we
still have this bifurcation between
country and historical country okay so
what can we do that I thought how do we
do historical Francisco Rodrigo do we
they're not exposed linguistically but
don't we have countries still in
historical country yes it's also a
circle country but we are not exposing
them in the what so with it so what
should happen this should give an
assuming to allow for a historical
country correct
how should this work I mean look if you
do dated this thing should evaluate to
the historical country
you
yes that one idea was to luckily like it
really really wants to the historical
countries polygons in conjugate them
right that's you tell me what the
historical country for us is United
States but okay but it's not exposed
linguistically all right and that's
really weird because it doesn't say ok
fine all right so let's put this in I
mean this is where I get upset about the
fact that we bundle all this work to get
all this data ok what's going on here
okay so now let's try doing it the range
to be the modern us
what does that mean you should write
your graphic sizing here this block is
not taking dated
okay so that's probably a bug
okay what's happening here you need a
very long
I need a polygon wrapper there
okay look this this the difficulty of
doing this is way okay
cool all right so now the question is I
don't know my history well enough the
people who were going out on this
frontier right is this something where
if I look at this for 1825 for example
it will presumably have expanded a bit
like you can see that border there
changed right
so you type on mute please that so the
question is is that a case where it is
more plausible that we should
interpolate or should we again only
gorge in a granular way I have no idea
what was happening here anybody want to
comment on this I don't know the history
for this particular case but I think we
should assume always steps look okay for
population for example it is much more
sensible to try interpolating even
though that might in principle be wrong
you know this is a much more sensible
plot than if we said date list step plot
I mean we could do this but but I think
it's the wrong thing to do
because I think it's better to you know
we get a better estimate of the
population by doing the interpolation
than we do by doing steps making sense I
think this is a silly thing to do and I
think we will also get crazy stuff like
if you try and work out the growth rate
it'll go crazy if you're doing it with
steps right but we hit then half
curate which properties we think we can
interpolate in which we cannot but this
perhaps doesn't depend so much in the
property it's truly in the history of a
thing because when the u.s. bought the
Louisiana they bought very much space
and I get I guess a lot of population as
one you are right so it's just depend on
the history and the user needs to know
what to use
alright so let's let's consider the
Louisiana Purchase so to speak and
consider the population data for the US
right boy that's a mess because that's
saying that there's a time series where
effectively we have continuous
interpolation and then we have a spike
you see what I'm saying now how do we
represent that in the time series go
sure we don't
so let's figure out how to do it yes
because I want one thing is to have the
time stamps very close you know you
would you would introduce yeah yeah I
understand
well that's possibility to time stamps
effectively on top of each other almost
yes mm-hmm
yeah if we specify instants we are not
saying what happens in between and there
is where interpolation is important but
if we specify intervals then we are
saying we we are specifying that we
assume it stays constant during that
interval and and then we don't need to
say anything about that's a fair point
yeah that's a fair point now the
question is could we have a time series
where we mix those two things not at the
moment
so I understand that that seems like a
reasonable way to go with this I mean
history is complicated and I think this
all right so look personally that's
that's a way to go but we've had other
problems here like this whole business
with the you know well okay so we've got
some bugs with dated but we also got to
deal with this problem of you know if we
say dated of United States dated of the
current entity United States comer 1820
that's got to do something reasonable my
making sense what are we going to have
that do this also ties back into our the
other conversation we've been having
about entities and ontology and the fact
that the the set of entities that apply
at any given point of time can change
I've never I have never really liked the
fact that we have country and historical
country
whereas countries as countries cease to
be they have to move into this other
entity type
what do you mean I mean the problem is
that countries you know it's somebody
you know some dictator takes over
somewhere and they rename the country
the Democratic Republic of the whatever
sure right and then all this these
things are all these things were
countries when they existed and there
they are still countries they're just
countries that don't exist anymore
this it's the historical XXX prefix that
I'm not crazy about because it seems
like a convenience for us to just call
one entity type to get a list of current
countries
hold on all right the most recent case
for example my country disagrees
split to keep the the main one has to
learn because they keep like this name I
mean it's just very weird because you
know in a change of control so to speak
like this piece of history I don't know
when when Cromwell took over in England
and the English Civil War
did they rename the country probably not
because the country didn't happen to
have you know something designating
monarchy and its name but then I mean
during the French Revolution did they
renamed France anybody no I mean
certainly there been plenty of countries
renamed maybe some South American knows
of isn't wasn't Venezuela renamed at
some point
but usually we take these real names as
the official name renamed so the way
people cause when it releases to
Venezuela even when they call officially
the Mariana wait wait but what counts as
a new country then so we're not you're
saying Venezuela can stay Venezuela but
it changes its name is that right right
yes the same happen in Poland after
communism fell it formally changed the
name but still it was the same point you
know you think about it well we have
wait a minute wait a minute I mean
during okay that that was true for that
but I mean if you take I don't know
Ukraine for example that was simply part
of the Soviet Union right yes it was it
was a part of it was like a it's like a
state in the Soviet Union and then it
became its own country yes right but so
so in that case okay
so let me just clarify what we're saying
here so why this is a mess okay do we
think we have a okay so you're claiming
that but but Sudan is not such a case
because Sudan is actually split or
Yugoslavia for Yugoslavia split into
multiple cont
right yeah so we move to Olivia into so
you can only exist right now in
historical country but something that's
right and we have country they pass
country entities they leave parts okay
okay fine I understand
um okay so what is so what is Allen
proposing I'm not sure and I'm proposing
and just this is a separate issue that
came up in another meeting and if we're
thinking about the right way to do
things I thought it's worth asking
whether this is the right way to do
things so in other words you're saying
we could imagine a an uber entity claude
type that is country sometime basically
right and then that there is a different
entity type which is current countries
perhaps or there's a property that says
whether something is currently extant or
whether it's defunct well but i think
this is the same issue as there's an
entity type that talks about mammals and
there's an entity type for general
species sure and I mean to say country
sometime
I think that's gonna get really weird as
well I mean I think there's no great
solution to this because I think that
this history is just kind of messy but
but the issue right now
one thing that's clear is that dated of
us comma 1820 better do something
reasonable now okay okay question if I
say dated of Roman Republic no Roman
Empire you know - 100 you know 100 BC
what should that do oh it's why was the
Roman Republic going to the Roman Empire
not just to rename like Venezuela why
was it a new country
what makes something a new country as
opposed to a renamed
you
that's interesting more a concept on
question lacing hand for example we have
the case of Germany where we have a
different struggle entity for the
Germany after 1990 or or the Germany's
when they were split or the Nazi Germany
circa 2008 those that those are many
different things right because East
Germany West Germany versus I mean and
now I'm gonna show my ignorance of
history but weren't the borders of Nazi
Germany comparable to the borders of
current germ of current unified Germany
in other words that no because they had
an truce and then they attacked other
countries and it was so that was after
but that was after they started walking
into other countries but but prior to
1933 or something didn't they have a I
guess okay Germany before nigelball we
can just look it up right we can just do
this presumably we have a historical
country do we have a historical country
Germany no what about pre that what
about 19 so it would count we would we
would consider it as why Marber republic
well in other words it wasn't Germany so
let's say 1931 for example and that's a
bad geo range to use you were right okay
okay okay so fair enough so its borders
were comparable but not the same okay
now tell me the difference okay but we
are choosing to make this so dated of
Germany and um dated of Germany comma
1931 what do we think that should do
have that dated of country always goes
to historical country just has to decide
which of the historical country entities
is the most interesting one and then
you'd have to have the current countries
inserted into historical country yes all
the current countries are already
sorry country so that's already gone and
yes the current countries with border
changes are in historical country is
that true yeah like we just saw for the
US where and also there is a proposal so
we already have the information in that
country about what could be considered
the successor and that's excellent
okay what's the successor entity to you
are
not only entity my husband's
success-oriented well I mean it could be
a rock I mean I don't know it's one way
to imagine a successor entity is to ask
I mean obviously we have some
overlapping oh go ahead what um what we
gonna say for example German Empire with
that's your money with German will
change right but for example I know my
part of the Italy so it's not the same
what breaks the chain of successor hard
to think about that great for now we can
we can a visualization at some point of
just what all the chains look like and
then okay I mean I think that seems
fairly non silly I mean so the question
is whether dated of Italy comma you know
100 AD what that should do and I think
nobody would reasonably expect that to
give you you know the Roman Empire are
you saying expect it so you'd expect
it's sort of look through mailed chain
of success but I mean to look through
that chain of succession to see if there
was a precursor or successor country
that had data in the requested bait and
return that and otherwise it fails well
I would say this is where it's
complicated and this is like Greece for
example Greece I think would like to
trake trace itself back to you know I
don't know what the Athenians and
whatever it is maybe maybe I'm wrong
about that but I mean they're a country
that
want to trace themselves back a long way
whereas Italy I don't think would claim
the Roman Empire as a predecessor maybe
it would maybe the Vatican would claim
the Roman Empire as predecessor I don't
know anybody have an opinion about do we
have history people on the school
yes we're okay do you have an opinion
about this a actually depends on how
they define the nation and what's up
well it's quite great as you already
helped all so we can track this back as
well as Francisco said we can trust tres
Germany buck all the way the Weimar
Republic or maybe the German Empire that
was before that but we cannot track that
down to maybe the Saxons or the Germans
I mean right before it was unified it's
tough to go back for example German that
was what was this Holy Roman Empire of
the German nation which consider itself
the continuation of the Roman Empire
which was you know what what about
weightily right so it is all over the
place in a way because you might think
you might think about this politically
so what what you know people consider
himself as an innovation but also you
may think geographically you know which
country occupied this region in a way
and then it transformed to something
else right well so look basically this
is a curation story I mean basically
there are things that people reasonably
consider to be ancestral countries and
so on and ones where they don't and you
know it's going to be a bit arbitrary
but I think there's a like like I would
think
what's a good example I mean the US
generally considers that it simply
didn't exist before you know before it I
mean it doesn't say the origin was some
you know American Indian tribe somewhere
it says it didn't exist whereas and
again oh that's a mess because obviously
it's a different you know it's folks
from a different part of the world gosh
that's a that's a weird then maybe
that's a weird I don't know if that's a
weird case or not what about the Vikings
and you know invading the north of
England I don't think they thought that
was a different country maybe I'm wrong
about that I don't know with King Canute
and all those guys um well I think so
look sounds to me like it's a curation
story that we basically just have to
decide for every current country you
know what we think it's reasonable yeah
I think this is the right way to do it
the first step is take every current
country and ask what it's reasonable
predecessors were but
time's it's gonna get really wacky
because like for instance in
well I don't and piece of history I
don't know but like the British Empire
for example when it had an island
somewhere I don't think that Island was
ever a nation
for you know something like you know
some country in Africa like I don't know
you know what I don't know let's say
Nigeria or something which I think was
some I don't know that one for sure but
but like um Zimbabwe well used to be
Rhodesia sand bob way now I don't know
that you've probably my pieces of
history is that the wrong country
but I think there were distinct
countries they just were part of the
British Empire but then there are other
places where there was a piece of LA
ash I think that I think the British had
some very elaborate way of
distinguishing these things but you know
when there was a piece of land that was
just directly okay anybody know this
history so I know you know like for
example the Congo prior to being a Dutch
colony was actually private property of
King what's-his-name
I'm blanking on it but you know yeah
yeah so before it was a territory of
Belgium it was his personal property he
just said this entire geo state is mine
and prior to that it was a collection of
tribes okay so where do we go with that
I mean that my basic point would be
go back take the current country and ask
you know what are the reasonable
predecessor countries the case where I
think it's awkward is where something
was taken over as a piece of some Empire
and was was not well like the case of of
Ukraine during the Soviet you know
Soviet period what do you do there
so the predecessor of Ukraine is surely
not the Soviet Union
because that will give really goofy
goofy stuff
so then perhaps we need to conditions
that is of reasonable of similar size
and of similar name gosh okay with them
what happens that then what happens to
Ukraine does it go does it here during
the Soviet period and then reappear as
you go before whenever it was taken over
1917 ish yes I'm that that may be
something we need to do because well we
don't have historical territory but say
for example you have the colonies all
the Spanish colonies in South America
they some world countries or some kind
of nation before or not but during the
time they were part of the Spanish
Empire then they became dependent
countries so they disappear as sorry
Asian somehow you know the expectation
is that administrative divisions if you
look at beyond a DM zero if you look
down to a DM ones and a DM twos and
things that you will see more continuity
is that the claim but that it may pop up
and down like it's unlikely that Ukraine
just disappeared it didn't you know
during the Soviet period it was merely a
part of the Soviet Union as opposed
right and intuition let's see right
right what example is Poland disappear
for over a hundred years it was split
into three countries for example if
you're looking for disappearance and the
reappearance okay so much for that
theory okay yeah this is some
gosh this is such a mess the um okay
well
um
now we have a number of interesting
comments on the livestream of people
with all kinds of pieces of history that
I don't know um
all right we'll look it seems to me
there is a an intuitive sense of
predecessor countries which may be
rather restricted and may have holes
like you would think go show that in the
case of Poland that it existed and then
he go back in history during the time I
suppose when that's pressure and stuff
like that if I'm remembering correctly
it simply didn't exist yes and before
that it existed is that true mm-hmm okay
so then that's what we have to do I
would imagine that if you say dated of
Poland comma I don't know what we say
whatever yes right that what would
happen it would simply say missing
mm-hmm okay but we we then independently
once who know we've already discussed
for a geo point we can absolutely know
what country what historical country if
we do a geo identify of a certain geo
point at a certain date that we can
answer you know what was this in 1875 or
something
yeah but that will answer of course the
historical country so no the successor
which I understand is again alright
that's what I'm saying but I mean then
the other thing one wants to know ok so
here's another way to do that if we
asked you identify of a region like for
example Poland right of current Poland
and you go back and you roll that back
to 1850 then the what it should answer
is whatever those three countries were
that that had pieces in what is now
Poland
right
see what I'm saying so in other words if
you want to know the answer to what was
you know what was Poland in 1850 you do
a Joe identify of Poland with dated 1850
and then it returns those three
countries
does that seem right
would you put them date it wouldn't be
around pollen because pollen is the
current pollen it will be around their
entity type
no I'm saying do you identify okay so
here's what I'm suggesting geo identify
i suture sang historical country yeah
you're right you're right you're right
you're right it's kind of a message both
historical country yeah it's kind of a
mess
so we have to say something like this
comma current Poland why is that a mess
that's exactly the scheme that we we're
working towards um okay
and if you wanted to know what countries
were in the same that what country is
overlapped with Poland as it existed in
some other year then you drive Poland in
a different date yeah
fair enough that seems perfectly
reasonable okay okay even at mid dated
of country of 1850 so the idea is that
as soon as you use dated with country it
automatically becomes historical country
yes that's what I think we should do for
the time being at least I mean I think
that okay so do I mean gee
rather than geo identifier what do I
mean no I mean joy I don't forget um
what is this so right now when you have
dated the entity and the entity type it
takes precedent so what will happening
entity value goes well you can specify
it twice they dated right now I think
it's taking the ones from the property
instead of them okay well that's
obviously wrong let's look at some of
the things on the live stream here okay
so um let's see yeah been on the live
stream says identifying regions for
southern Africa is gonna be incredibly
difficult since the fluid Kingdom ranges
which overlaps with competing
colonization forces yeah I mean you know
that's that's kind of the lie of some of
these country borders where you go back
you know there wasn't clear what the
border of a country meant um and I think
you know when we have our geostatistics
die I think it's I think it's just crazy
to have like a distribution I mean I
think we we just have to say this the
best best shot we've got at defining
this I don't really think there's
another way to do it um
now
okay end up with Kingdom some which
became their own countries like
Swaziland and others which integrated
into nations like Zulu land which is
part of South Africa
restore the polish-lithuanian
Commonwealth okay that's some not not
our problem to solve
um improve the interpreter resolution
mechanism if I want to do
okay now what's this this is Oh
plaint here is that something about our
official names like this don't interpret
is that true do we fail on that
you
Wow that's horrifying so we can't
round-trip there
we should so if we do Bolivia oops
and then we say full name or something
oops I wanted
okay but that we public and roundtrip
but we the problem is we can't roundtrip
that seems like a curation assume and
seems like something we should solve
yeah okay that did fine all right
I think that's a simple curation Aesir
yeah um
where did those forms come from did
somebody just had those from someone
lied on the live stream this was content
on this okay maybe headed from another
source they're fine um that's why we
should be able to tweak that to just
allow I would think so those cases
deviations yeah this whole can of worms
I don't think this I mean that's just
it's a countries and territories I mean
that's part of our definition of entity
types is the fine print says it's a
country or it's a territory right so
code etc yes that's why we cause here
that country fair enough um yeah
comments about African borders obviously
incorrect for ethnic types of this
Africa yeah well that's that's the
nature of political history the
what is this this is do we already
discuss this now
this double double-dated business yes
that's what I was saying that right now
it's taking into account so it takes
presence they're dated from the property
set up okay fine so that's essentially a
bug
well there wasn't really which one
shouldn't be something there isn't okay
well okay so we're wait wait wait wait
wait why do we need okay so if we have
both
let's think about that in this case
cases where Allen other other cases
where we can distinguish those two
I mean they're like what are we okay so
look there's there's a dated rapper that
could go around the entity type the
entity or the property okay so the
question is which takes precedence in
that situation
I mean I wouldn't mind generating a
message if you have conflicting data
well it might be fall today I still use
DC voltage button with an extra message
about saying that that's fine I would
tend to think hmm I mean I can see
arguments on both sides for being the
entity that wins versus it being the
property that wins
you
anybody got any other thoughts on the
summon because
can imagine is code that loops over
properties for a whole bunch of entities
I mean I just don't know well III think
it makes more sense what we have right
now because actually they're the one
that takes the attribute of the date is
their property all right fine
so let's have properties take precedence
and generate a message effect inflict
fair not okay we're really running out
of time but let's see if we can just now
cheer functions and how to treat
entities with time series of polygons
geo within queue what's wrong with this
it looks wonderful
it's actually well it's according to say
we have for handling geo polygons
well how they're in polygons have a time
series yeah we can use the geographic
functions with those cases because we
can retrieve a dated polygon that time
so we can compare them as regular
polygons it sounds great for me yes
that's that's our current state so right
now our main question would be okay so
we have these entities that don't return
just polygons with a time series of
polygons so what are the considerations
you have to take or we deal with this
kind of cases but this one we already
have a default because Geographics of
Roman Empire does something definite
right it shows just a full extent the
maximum extent of it's not work can we
please make this work
can we please make cheerless plotted
country work it's there a problem with
that
guys is there a problem
historical country working so let's make
it work
please okay so this is the maximum
extent is that correct yeah okay so will
it yes right so this is a polygon of the
roman republic that had been sent so it
doesn't cover all the union of all the I
understand I understand so which is kind
of a hacky thing but I don't see what
else I mean I don't know whether there
are many countries which have very
confusing aspects of that like where
they started off having a big extent to
the west and then they ended up losing
that and having a big extent to the east
no idea um we shifted after World War
Two okay
okay interesting all right well so then
I mean so if we do
you
okay so that I've no idea what that can
you recognize that what is that it's the
current state of affairs okay is that
the best ever state of affairs or is
there a different one that is some well
that's not the best so give me where
seventeen Trice I don't know sixteen
fifty swingin Commonwealth and such
you could try fourteen ninety or
something oh boy oh okay what's called
something different then this is the
speed if I say by the way linguistically
Poland in 1490 what am I gonna get to
that point because was already United we
were messed up in 13th century you know
okay so what is that it is can I give
that entity instance to this or did
early 2000 since 1390 so for 1870 okay
I'm glad you were paying attention in
school when they were teaching yes
that's why I'm just feeling like okay
well so we obviously call that yet
something different but does the sense
of the instance thing work does anybody
know will that work inside that polygon
and things but this violated that the
default historical country polygon is
the case of greatest extent seems like
it's not a totally stupid default
but I see I see it this might be the
case of greatest extent for Poland as
things call Poland as opposed to the
polish-lithuanian Commonwealth um fair
enough so we may have done the right
thing here
and great extent is defined as maximum
area not maximum extent lat/long so to
speak okay so what's wrong with that so
that therefore I claim that the default
interpretation if you just give the
historical country is the maximum extent
polygon is there a problem with that I
see you're asking a different question
should we scan through the whole history
of the Roman Republic to ask whether
essentially the the union of all Roman
Republic points contained Vesuvius right
so the question is when doing lookups if
we shouldn't stick to this concept of
using the maximum extent or we should
extend to use the full well in Syria
that would be the question right but if
you do an intersection of the regions um
the let's see okay so one one suggestion
is given you know Roman Republic for
example we should have a property of
that that is the union of all territory
that was ever contained in it that will
be a useful thing to have
making sense so in other words one thing
is the polygon but there's also the
aggregated polygon or something be sure
I'm saying
Raisa so that may be a robbery that's
that's what I'm saying that's not the
polygon property that's some kind of
aggregated polygon
right and then that would be the thing
so you could imagine with Jill within
queue checking against the aggregated
polygons if you didn't specify anything
else
so there's a default polygon you just
asked for roman republic polygon you get
the polygon a maximum extent if you ask
for aggregated polygon which might be
the default in jail with NQ
that makes sense this may be a Jeff
Orient yes and that's what I was
thinking but maybe for that kind of
thing we should wait to satisfy that
will be kept where I see the default the
default for polygon could be kept but
we'd say
so because this is for circle conscious
but maybe we could define them as we're
saying for example aggregated all areas
will be rated Aria a key word for that
yeah it's not a bad idea I mean we
haven't even talked about principle
areas and things like that for
historical countries like like for
example let's take the British Empire
for instance you know arguably the I
don't even know what you know is the
principal area of the British Empire
Britain or is it the whole you know
thing that was always colored pink on
the maps that I had when I was a kid
there for example in the definition of
country data we defined it the principal
area we excluded the colonies of the
people are you okay yeah so the colonies
could be considered dependencies no not
that's okay fair enough but then in that
case have we done that for historical
countries so like for the gun show right
now okay so that's that's another thing
we should look at the colonies from the
main the
ah okay
but so what
the possible interpretations of geo with
NQ by the way question on the livestream
points on the livestream about about you
know in current events you know what are
we what given that we're going to all
this trouble with historical countries
maybe we can do something better with
disputed borders in the current time
what do we do with cashmere right now
you
you
I know we were using polygons from what
open supermarket now we were using the
polygon from OpenStreetMap which song
called tried to take the division from
you at some point that's well that's oh
so in that case a fine print says the
attempted fine print is whatever the UN
says is what we're saying
that the notion point yes that what we
try at not sure if that's the best view
well I understand but I mean I could
imagine using geo variant to deal with
disputed territories
Allen do you have any comments on this
possibly your you're suggesting that we
have the Indian view on the on the bid
geo geo variant that's a disputed
territory somehow tagged with which
point of view where exactly the the Geo
variant widget would be yeah according
to country X if yeah I mean that will
give you know huge can of worms right
for Taiwan for example that's a huge can
of worms
you have to if you do that then in some
countries point of view other countries
do not actually exist
I exist
I mean recognized by the concede so that
you can see P recognizes the one but not
Jim not what so so that you can see P
recognizes the one but not mainland
China China over not my lunch I know
what recognizers means that's probably
not the main I mean it's not that they
claim that there's a blank on the map
right but maybe they label that part of
the moustache
well okay okay but look the use of Geo
variant to deal with disputed areas is
something we maybe should consider but I
think that's not so you've got four
different interpretations for Joe within
queue is that correct yes we have
different ways to try to attempt to say
okay what do we want to mean really when
we say goe think you Roman Republic and
Vesuvius
should we just in the operationalize but
actually what you already said is just
set the default maximum area polygon
versus demand Mount Vesuvius which is
something we already do in a trivial way
okay well so but but right okay but I'm
beginning to think that a better
interpretation of point within area
happens if it's a Geo within queue of a
historical country within another
historical country and that's our query
number - that is way below okay
well but so the question is no no but
I'm not the Silvius which is a point
right yes oh I see
- second query thoughts below yep so
maybe we could start using this variant
for making a difference within the same
let's say the question is if you say is
Italy within the you know no let's take
another example is
oh gosh what's a good example is here's
a good example is Lithuania within the
Soviet Union
right so if I'm not mistaken at some
point Lithuania had a big Empire
and so it would not be the case that for
all of history Lithuania has been within
the borders I'm claiming I don't
actually know this for sure has been
within the borders of the aggregated
polygon of the Soviet Union in other
words the aggregated polygon of
Lithuania has pieces that extend beyond
the aggregated polygon of the Soviet
Union I claim I don't know if that's
correct history but assume that's
correct history
but so it's one thing if the you know if
for example
that every piece of I don't know Bella
Russia or something Belarus the was some
uh everything that's ever been Belarus
has always been contained was contained
within the maximum polygon of the Soviet
Union which is probably true right
temporal so if you're asking you know
during the duration of Soviet Union was
we to any part of Soviet Union yes right
you're right you're right you're right
if you ask about the pure pieces of land
it might not be true but while while the
Soviet Union existed was it always part
the answer might be yes mm-hmm actually
that might not be true either because
I'm sure there was a time when for all
of those countries you know before they
were invaded so to speak there was a
time when the Soviet Union existed you
know when it hadn't yet got to Estonia
or something right so the answer to that
will be false I mean even if it's only
right I'm sure if we look at the
historical polygons there we'd find that
so the question is look this is a
question of default from the default may
not be all that useful here is to find a
way of projecting the collection so for
polygons in time to a single budget just
look polygons could be the first the
maximum the Union well right but I mean
that that's what I'm saying the the egg
what I was calling the aggregate polygon
is the Union polygon for a given country
yes perhaps you can give to the use of
the freedom through your variant of
which method to use to mine I see as
Scotia points out there's another case
which is the time you know it's a it's a
space-time problem it's not a just a
space problem so the question is can the
space-time there and can the Geo variant
also represent a space-time I mean so
let's zoom out for a moment okay so
we're just now getting the
one-dimensional day tenth of all stuff
four times working I believe
Eve as we do this spatial statistics
stuff are we going to wind up getting
the spatial analog of that working or is
that not part of that project go should
you happen to know
no I mean well at this point we use we
use but we actually work with entities
if they have polygons specified but in
our special project we do not take we do
not take dates in a way so if you if you
give a date at polygon it's gonna be a
fixed region in space ten years we can
work with that
I understand but but but you could ask
things like you know does such and such
a thing intersect with such and such a
thing the issue is okay so look it's a
hierarchy it's like temporal logic
spatial logic and then there's also a
spatio temporal logic right so at this
point we we take whatever the geo
intersection from we will gonna inherit
whatever the Geographics kind of he's
doing at this point fair enough so if
you decide whatever you know kind of
decide on on how you work with this in
entity world will just inherit that okay
so this raises the question of is there
a form of graphics I mean we talked
earlier about showing you know a time
series Geographics time series using
opacity basically to just what you're
doing is every year you put another
layer of opacity down and then the years
where the country was there a lot the
points where the country was there for
many years
it'll be darker than the places where
the country wasn't there for many years
but we could also imagine I suppose a
you know two plus one dimensional thing
where we actually have a stack of geo
plots going you know going in a Z
Direction is that a crazy thing it's
probably pretty crazy I'm trying to
understand the way to describe I mean
what we ultimately want is this
spatio-temporal surface or a spatial
temporal volume right that represents
the
you know the historical borders of the
country if I'm not mistaken and then we
can ask questions about that like of
that spatio-temporal thing okay so
question for in in the regions in the
whole computational geometry system we
could perfectly well deal with that
object couldn't we right so one question
is can we generate that so given I mean
what we should see is for the Roman
Empire for example we should see this
thing maybe that one comes into
existence as a big slab of stuff but
eventually you know some countries might
start at a point I don't know as as I
don't know Venice for example might
start at you know point and then expand
and make a big Empire and then contract
back to a point again in this spatial
temporal way so we could imagine making
the 3d surface that is that and yeah
it's a I mean it's a world it's not
quite a world sheet what what the heck
is it it's a world it's not a world line
it's what what are you saying
well tube or world you'll be okay world
tube okay fair enough
I'm pretty soon we'll be doing string
theory on countries as well um but no
okay so
fair enough so we could imagine making
such a thing and being able to convert I
mean it might be fun to just try and
make some of those and see whether
they're useful because if we got that
and we can do geo coordinates right so
let's say in that world tube that we
successfully could have geo coordinates
and time coordinates then in principle
okay so I don't know what the state of
the region system supporting unit says
does anybody know right but so if the
unit's are so by the way this case and
it's worth communicating that to the
region people that the case where the
units are not the same in different
dimensions
which I bet they have not considered
right because what you want is a you
know the units in one direction you know
miles or whatever and in the other
direction of years right so can somebody
communicate that who can communicate
that to the computational geometry folk
okay then but then you know so in other
words the Roman Empire could be
considered to have a certain you know in
units of square miles by by years it had
a certain extent that should be
interesting to know now I'm very curious
this is the kind of question that
Christopher would like is which country
has had the highest you know spatial
temporal volume in history um okay
propriety China you
in China okay well we can um actually
it's a shame Christopher isn't on this
call he knows a lot about these these
random things um okay well we polish and
wrap up here but but so we basically
have not resolved this question of what
geo within you should exactly do
without a fair assessment
yep um but we can start exploring all
these your variant okay things that will
be useful yeah
and then if you implement some of those
then
right um
oh gosh
because God will also mean that we
waited we dated and an interval or all
how we will consider the dated rapper
when it's nothing like I understood yeah
right that's an interesting one as well
I mean I think I think this notion of a
spatio temporal world tube thing maybe
what we'll end up having to think about
because I don't really see how uh what
else what else is dated Roman Empire
comma interval
I mean one could choose to say it's the
it's the Union but I think that's a wimp
out
because
I mean these are these are tricky
question
that this was Lithuania always within
the Soviet Union
right it's it's a little unclear what
you mean by that I mean if we were doing
that as a natural language thing we
might have some assuming surround that
should think about what okay let's give
this challenge let's consider these
kinds of weird cases of Geo with in
queue and so on and let's consider what
is the natural language version of the
queries that would lead to these
different things and then what assuming
x' will be generate to represent these
different the different cases
okay and maybe that can help inform what
we actually want to do because in fact
we probably do want to have you know we
will want to make these work a more
powerful with assuming x' and so on um
the okay let's just look at the
livestream quickly oh okay that's an
interesting I did not know that piece of
history Kashmir is a Pakistani
population but has a Hindu King okay
Transnistria is recognized by no nations
but fought a war against Moldova as a
country
Wow well again this is one of these you
know it's it's like you know if it has a
UN code then it's a country and if it
doesn't then it isn't from our point of
view I mean which is kind of a wimp out
but it's because we're not you know in
that business um
let's see
oh that's an interesting idea if you use
dated of historical country comma all to
mean the Union
you know the Union Territory for example
well that's image an idea go ahead yes
that's something we should explore on
but you said that mining also the volume
right but I mean the problem is if you
say dated of historical country comma an
interval of dates and then you do
Geographics of that I think I think
ultimately we want this opacity thing
for that and then all might want to be
the you know the complete opacity story
rather than the pure Union story okay um
oh I see another comment here that um
okay our geometric computation team is
during the livestream tomorrow at 1:00
p.m. Eastern um
about new features in geometric
computation in version 12 so for people
on the livestream who are interested in
such stuff do tune in alright we should
wrap for now we are going to have to
continue this um boy so many complicated
issues ho boy
oh wow yeah this is complicated
I'm telling you space-time is what we're
gonna have to talk about
yeah does jail within cumene geo date
within queue or not
see you could want either thing you
shouldn't have used for Sue vyas is your
first example because it's too easy well
not necessarily it depends on how much
of the serious blew up but know that the
mountain was still there
is there much left of Krakatoa I don't
know um do we have a notion of Krakatoa
does that is that a
you
it's a volcano but um
ah
you
Cerf is asking if there's a way to get
include all territories from lots of
nations that's what geo variant is
supposed to do right
geo variant can give you that content
right with all areas that's there
oh that's all areas means so if I do
that for the US what's gonna happen if I
say geo list plot of G ovarian of United
States
all areas is this kind of show Guam and
things as well
why is it taking so long is this not
cached huh yes it shows and will support
the repo which asked the that's
interesting okay cool so that's the
answer to such question um thanks for
the comments on the livestream that this
has been interesting yes we've been
working on history for a long time and
it's a it's some this is only the yeah
this is just a corner of what has had to
be done there um check out military
conflicts for another another giant can
of worms that we think we've got
reasonable resolution on um alright well
thanks to everybody here we will have to
continue this hopefully within a week or
so um and thanks for all the comments on
the livestream and hopefully we didn't
offend too many countries and so on in
this discussion um ok thanks everybody
bye